six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number let's go next
to our caller from the 407 area code
caller from 407 go ahead who's this 407
are you with us oh sorry yeah mmm you
know I called back or called the show
once before Jojo remember I don't
remember offhand I hope you'll accept my
apology but I would love to hear what
may is uh making you call in today the
crazy conspiracy things that I just
thought up no it's kind of you had a
conspiracy like folks around it anyways
here's the thing I was thinking about
like since Trump is doing the whole
dismantling of Obama's thing in the
green energy plan I mean like what would
be the future for power plants because I
had an idea like you know how people use
petal generators for that like why not
do the same thing that if you had a
generator at home yeah have the homeless
do that for money so they can you know
really need and all that hey let me ask
you this are you familiar with the
anthology series black mirror know do
you have access to a Netflix account you
know okay if you can get access to a
Netflix account there is an episode
about exactly this basically people
peddling to earn credits for energy
creation which then becomes a currency
that they can spend it is very very
dystopian so a lot of a lot of dystopian
stuff going on in your mind I think for
better or worse no it's it could be
check out the episode and then maybe
call back appreciate the call pedaling
for power certainly certainly an
interesting idea